Welcome back everyone, Doctor Strange's here
to destroy your universe that is going to
be my full marvel what if episode four video
obviously all about dark Doctor Strange's origin story
So this going to be a big deal.
I'll explain what's can happen with him in
the future the MCU as well to because this
all plays into what's happening in later episodes
of what if if you're brand-new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
will be doing videos for all the episodes
this season, and we have the Hawkeye episodes
that are coming up after this careful for
spoilers if you have not see the episode yet.
There were so many Easter eggs and references
in this to.
If you're a big fan of Doctor Strange comics
are you been watching the marvel movies.
There a lot of callbacks to earlier marvel
movies some is destroying the universe in
this time they can't pin it all on Spider-Man.
There were a lot of you that thought the Doctor
Strange was acting kind of weird during the
Spider-Man no way home trailer.
Also talk about that while in talk about Easter
egg from this episode, because this is obviously
a Doctor Strange that when completely off
the rails.
It does seem like Doctor Strange goes a little
off the rails during Spider-Man no way home.
But starting with the title of the episode.
What if Doctor Strange lost his heart instead
of his hands where Christine Palmer dies in
the car crash that originally took his hands
in the main MCU timeline version of the origin
story the episode starts with that same twilight
zone inspired voiceover narration from the
watcher talking about the multiverse.
Alternate timelines, how people making different
choices create whole new branches of alternate realities
Like during the Loki finale.
This time though it's more about people making
bad choices as they reference several times
in the episode.
Like in some of the what if scenarios in some
of the episodes characters do go completely
off the rails.
But the endings a little more positive this
time.
It just like a complete downer ending like
everything just goes completely to crap.
But the actual beginning of the episode starts
with his silhouette staring down from the
New York city skyline watching Doctor Strange
driving is Lamborghini the pickup Christine
for a date and he asked the question what
if the alternate choice that is made is the wrong one
Even if Doctor Strange had good intentions
if it wasn't clear it is Benedict Cumberbatch
who came back to do the voice of Doctor Strange
for the episode, Rachel McAdams came back
to do the voice of Christine, Benedict Wong
came back is Wong and Tilda Swinton came back
to the voice of the ancient one.
So pretty much the entire main cast came back
to their voices.
They are champs there was also a special cameo
is really brief.
Like blinking amiss.
It's all pointed out when we get to that part
of the episode, so technically there was another
MCU actor they came back to do their voice
for the special cameo.
But apparently Christine likes creme brulee
I don't remember her ever referencing that
in the original Doctor Strange movie.
I do believe that Rachel McAdams is coming
back for Doctor Strange multiverse of madness.
So the ideas will learn more about her character
during that movie.
We never really got to see their relationship
make it that far in the main MCU universe.
But I believe it's implied the Doctor Strange
is still in love with her in present day.
The same way that Tony Stark was always in
love with Pepper Potts even though he didn't
actually see them get together right away.
She references the title of the episode of
the theme of the episode.
Asking him to get to the heart of it today
that there on is actually heading to a dinner
in honor of him for this medical procedure
the just pulled off successfully the also
this will joke about him not understanding
television shows, because she mentions the
prices right and he has no idea what she's
talking about.
Like the prices what too busy studying to
be an amazing surgeon to watch television
the medical procedure that she says that he
did that they're honoring him for a radical
hemisphere ectomy is actually a real thing.
It's a very hard-core type of surgery were
half of a person's brain is either removed
or separated from the other half is a major
major procedure.
So is very rare but the whole idea is that
Doctor Strange inside the MCU is an amazing
genius level surgeon.
So he's one of the few people could pull it
off.
The procedure is also meant to be a metaphor
setting up the payoff at the end of the episode
with the two different versions of Doctor
Strange being separated from each other is
variance Doctor Strange plays it fast and
loose really aggressive with the slow truck
driver trying to pass almost getting to erect
but saving it until the car behind the rear
ends them and they have the accident the kills
Christine the whole sequence of events here
is also meant to be a metaphor for the entire
episode and Doctor Strange himself this version
Doctor Strange being extra aggressive, impulsive
taking unnecessary risks and even though he's
usually skilled enough to handle those wrist
like pull this off unforeseen complications.
Side effects wind up causing him to FUBAR
the whole thing in this case it leads to the
utter destruction of the entire universe rest
have in the chat to pay respects to his entire
reality, although he did survive at the end.
I will explain that to that small protective
cocoon that he's in survives the end of the episode
That's all meant to be set up for future episodes
during her funeral scene.
If it wasn't clear all these of the people
standing around him in her grave are Christine's
family Doctor Strange did have a brother and
sister in the comics a long time ago, but
his sister died when he was very young.
Tragically and his brother was part of this
weird storyline that Marvel never really referenced again
So he's not really in MCU thing with the ideas
that in losing his heart metaphorically.
He isn't humbled in the way he was in the
main MCU universe.
He's the same supersmart but super arrogant
person the Tony Stark was before he got his
origin story in the cave and changed his ways.
So that's why this Doctor Strange blows through
his training superfast he is just as apt and
full of potential for power as the main MCU
Doctor Strange, but he's got that edge to him
Like no limits version of Doctor Strange,
so connecting things to the Spider-Man no
way home trailer with this version Doctor
Strange that seems way more arrogant than
other versions that we seem like just saw
during avengers endgame in Avengers infinity
war part of what I think is going on with
him is that really is Doctor Strange I don't
think this Mephisto.
Even though they're doing Spider-Man one more
day storyline in during that it was Mephisto.
But the writer of Doctor Strange 2 talked
about Doctor Strange.
As if by the time that movie rolls around,
he's become a much more powerful, more arrogant
version of himself.
So it makes sense that he would think that
he's powerful enough to handle a spell.
Like change in the timeline here that Wong
warns him not to use is not that is gone completely dark
It just that he's overreaching a little bit
in the way that Tony Stark Iron Man always
overreached over did things in the MCU that
that's how we got to Ultron.
So for the early part of the episode.
They come speedrun the plot of the original
Doctor Strange movie up to the point where
he finds the I have Okamoto and learns about
the time stone the scene of Wong in the ancient
one yelling at him about changing time destroying
reality obviously foreshadows what happens
at the end of the episode, but is also the
same speech that they gave him in the original
Doctor Strange movie when he mentions Cagliostro
who's lost books of Magic he uses to try and
save Christine in the episode Cagliostro is
actually pretty big Doctor Strange character
he's originally the sorcerer in the marvel
universe who's able to use the darkhold to
achieve immortality which they kind of reference
later in the episode in the MCU, canonically
he was also one of the earlier members of
the ancient ones order who use dark magic
as well as the I have Okamoto and the time
stone to manipulate the timeline in the book
of Cagliostro as mentioned during the first
Doctor Strange movie, but he's typically viewed
as a Doctor Strange villain in the comics.
Like another dark sorcerer on par with Kai
silliest and his followers.
Even though the way they treat the character
during this episode is a little bit different.
But then they go back to the montage in they
speedrun the rest of the plot of the original
Doctor Strange movie in really like the actual
episode plot doesn't start till right after
the end of the Doctor Strange movie.
Like he beats dormammu dormammu have come
to bargain become sorcerer supreme the ancient one dies
Just like she did in the original movie, then
what would be the time between the events
of the original Doctor Strange movie in his
crossover with Thor in the events of Thor Ragnarok
He sits looking out the window pining for
Christine thinking about using the time stone
till Wong comes along and tells him not to
come have some tea which of course he doesn't
listen to and then he starts to use the time
stone almost the same way that he used it
during avengers infinity war looking it alternate
timelines trying to find the one in 14 million
chance where he could save Christine's life.
But the difference here is they do not just
looking at different timelines, he's not just
peeping them, he's actually using the time
stone to physically take himself back in the timeline
So he's fully time traveling rest during infinity
war.
He was really just speed running scanning
the different timelines looking for the one
in 14 million chance and they play it like
a complete montage of failure like you kind of sense
the way this is going the distress a bunch
of different alternate routes, but because
it's an absolute point in time, no matter
what he does she always dies in some way the
Loki series made it seem like the infinity
stones were keys to creating nexus event.
But I think the idea here is that the rule
about absolute points in time supersedes the Loki explainer.
Like no matter what some of events can't be
changed less the paradox completely collapse
all of reality and you start to notice how
in all these timelines.
When he's trying you see flashes of green
light around the frames which are meant to
be references to the time stone energy as
of time itself is acting to maintain Christine's
absolute point in time where she dies, so
just to be clear it's not he who remains Kang
who is actually changing the timeline so that
she always dies he's not affecting any of
this, you kind of wonder though in the TVA
would step in to try and stop him and here's
we get our special cameo scene, so there's
one reality where he stands her up gets drunk
at a bar instead and she still winds up dying
and what seems like a gas explosion or building
the new station is WHIH which they use in
all the marvel movies.
All the TV shows we saw than during Wandavision
as well.
It's Leslie Bibb's Christine Everhart character
reporting on the debt she came back to do
the voice for the short cameo scene the sad
music track this playing while this montage
of failure is happening is music from the
original Doctor Strange movie and finally
the ancient one appears to him explaining
absolute points in time and how if she had not died
He would never become sorcerer supreme save
the universe from dormammu then gives him
the same type of warning that Wong gave him
earlier in the episode.
The path is on only these the darkness in
the end of this reality, which it does by
the end of the episode.
Turns out she was right on the money and she
winds up attacking him to try and save the universe
But what she does here is that she actually
creates this unique kind of nexus event getting
to the Loki connection here.
She uses dark magic from dormammu's dimension
to create a nexus event that splits them into
variance, but allows them to coexist in the
same timeline in the same reality.
Whereas under normal circumstances had she
not used her magic spell they would just splintered
off into completely separate alternate realities,
one of them goes back to the sanctum and just
stays they're not using the time stone to
go back in time.
The other one goes on to become dark Doctor
Strange going into the distant past to find
Cagliostro and here's the thing he actually
does find Cagliostro he kind of calls that
on the episode.
Like dear messing with me please tell me you're
not Cagliostro yourself and even though the
person says no my name is obeying that's just
one of Cagliostro's many names from the comics,
so really is Cagliostro just messing with
him really cool connection to the Doctor Strange
movies as well.
Cagliostro is the great-grandfather of Baron
more know in the comics, which is why he kind
of resembles him.
Although the reason why his eyes are different
colors are because he kind of went to the
same version of what dark Doctor Strange does
later in the episode trying to change the
absolute point in time later in the episode.
They have the conversation where he talks
about death being this natural part of life
and the reason why he knows this is because
he lived through it himself.
Like he's basically saying that he created
the books the Doctor Strange is using to change
the absolute point in time because he himself
at some point in his history lost someone
that he wanted to bring back to life, he leads
him to what seems like his ancient version
of the sanctum.
Maybe somewhere in the region of Mesopotamia.
It's kind of hard to place this just based
on the architecture originally comic book
Cagliostro lived during 1000 A.D. and ruled
over an area inside India and then they play
the same joke about his name from the original
movie.
This time though is about the making fun of
his Armani suit.
Okay sorcerer Armani.
Let's go you notice when he finds the book
on time manipulation it has dormammu sigil
in it is because originally in the MCU Cagliostro
use dark magic to power his spells.
But he learns the key to obtaining all this
power to break the absolute point in time
just by absorbing other more powerful beings
into himself absorbing their power, but they
take this literally during the episode, which
is why he eventually looks like this freaky
monster with tentacles in all kinds of different
appendages and horns sticking out the first
creature that he summons for the multiverse
probably looks familiar you pry recognize
it from what if episode 1.
It's the exact same creature the captain carter
fought in her universe.
Even though she wound up killing it during
her episode, you have to remember that that's
happening later in the timeline.
Then when this is happening because dark Doctor
Strange into the distant past.
But this time, he winds up losing the fight
that barely escaped with his life that's when
he gets the idea that he can't be nice about
it.
He just has to take power from other creatures.
There are several different montages.
Just to let you know how much time is going
by hundreds of years go by during all these
different encounters eventually he grows the
comic book OT he starts wearing a darker theme
version of his comic book costume he absorbs
a garden gnome that just a regular known for
the marvel universe gnomes come from both
Asgard and from this pocket dimension called
Otherworld he takes his new cloak from a magical
insect creature.
I'm not exactly sure which creature this is
supposed to be some of these are actually
big comic book Easter eggs and some of them
I think are just unique random magical creatures.
So if you think you know what all these different
creatures are just right them blown the comments.
I believe the giant mystical Raven that he
absorbs is meant to be a version of marvel's
Raven from the idea verse.
Which is like this pocket multiverse were
all the literary characters live from books.
So the Raven is the mystical Raven from Edgar
Allen Poe's Raven poem he absorbs what seems
like one of surtur's fire dragons from his
realm we saw Thor fight one.
During Thor Ragnarok the two-headed ran that
he absorbs I believe is meant to be a version
of the Egyptian God almond raw the giant skeletal
being with red horns and a Kate kind of reminds
me of a version of nightmare the giant back
creature that he takes.
I think is meant to be a version of beth Dragon
from the comics, it appeared as a Godzilla
villain when Marvel published Godzilla stories.
So was it straight up kaiju monster watcher
notices and going off the rails and thinks
to intervene even though he's forbidden to
do so, claiming that if he were to intervene
to save this universe it with threatened the
rest of the multiverse.
Although he never fully explains what that
means during this episode I think will learn
more about what he was talking about in future
episodes.
Like the threat to the multiverse is a teaser
that they'll pay off in later episodes.
You notice the Doctor Strange is gross.
So powerful now absorbing all these beings
that he can sense the watcher's presence the
stack he absorbs I believe is meant to be
a version of or in who's a God who lived during
the height boring and age the Conan comics
timeline and was worshiped by the stag cold.
I'm not sure who this snake like creature
is supposed to represent, but is another giant
legit snake that reminded me of the midgard
serpent, which almost appeared during avengers
infinity war in Norse mythology.
It's also one of Loki's children.
But not inside the MCU little bit different
in the MCU of the Bucky's also called the
white wolf in the MCU now.
But this white wolf is just meant to be a
random mystical creature from the multiverse
is not one of the panther gods or one of the
Tiger gods worshiped by the tribes of Wakanda.
That would've been bad ass to see dark Doctor
Strange absorb the panther God inside the
MCU they cut to his perspective for the last
couple of flashes here of him taking on the
characteristics of the monsters that he absorbs
so that's why he has two heads here why he
turns into this flame.
Like creature because he absorbed an elemental
what he looks kind like in insectoid in all
this other crazy monsters then finally he's
become powerful enough to actually take some
of the hydra's power.
So, because a couple of its tentacles off
and because were still in the distant past.
It survives into the modern era where Capt.
Carter, winds up finding it later, they reveal
hundreds of years of gone by in this version
of Cagliostro chose to live out his normal
lifespan to die of old age when Doctor Strange
says he can use the time stone to help him
live forever that just a reference to comic
book Cagliostro using the darkhold to become
immortal then when he references the other
Doctor Strange will realize that death is
a necessary thing he's only living have a
life.
It's him referencing that he knew what the
ancient one did this whole time.
Creating the nexus event splitting them into
two timeline versions and foreshadowing the
big Doctor Strange versus Doctor Strange fight
then a psychic impression of the ancient one
comes through a tear in reality like she says
like an echo of the original ancient one after
she's dead to warn Doctor Strange and explain
how she created the special kind of nexus
event using dark magic the whole world is
kind of melting away into black do nothingness.
This is basically reality crumbling it explains
that in trying to undo Christine's death is
absolute point in time, the dark Doctor Strange's
temporal paradox will fundamentally destroy
the fabric of reality in the universe that
supposed to be the reason for the rule why
you cannot change absolute points in time,
you also notice when good Doctor Strange and
Wong are preparing for the fight he's not
wearing the time stone.
I think that is more in service of being able
to tell them apart when they're fighting each
other on screen later in the episode.
The guardians of Ashanti spell that Wong creates
is a big comic book reference to the Ashanti
or a trio of ultra powerful gods in the marvel
universe that act as patrons for sorcerer
supreme to invoke their power.
So in the comics, Doctor Strange draws most
of the magic that he uses to power his spells
from the shanty in the MCU they try to be
more scientific about it.
Saying that he pulls energy from other dimensions,
but they do reference to the shanty during
the first Doctor Strange movie, then dark
Doctor Strange pulls good Doctor Strange into
his summoning circle that he's been using
to steal power from all these different creatures
and tries to win him to his because I love
the way this is basically Benedict Cumberbatch
acting with himself.
Like he's playing both of these different
characters, but he's having to play one of
them super crazy.
Thus they have their full blown wizard battle
is a super cool fight.
I wish they would've gotten this crazy during
avengers infinity war and Avengers endgame
with the magic battles, but I'm assuming that
they will get this crazy during Doctor Strange
multiverse of madness because Doctor Strange
is so much more powerful and you have scarlet
witch with her chaos magic, who's even more
OP yourself when they're fighting you notice
some of the spells they're using art of the
same spells from avengers infinity war.
The two cloaks start fighting each other.
Which is awesome the cloak of levitation versus
the dark cloak and it uses the same trick
from avengers infinity war binding his hands
is that he can't spell cast like binding Thanos
his hands so that he can snap the infinity
gauntlet that RIP cloak of levitation the
cloak did nothing wrong good Doctor Strange
attempts the same spell that the ancient one
used earlier to split dark Doctor Strange
into alternate versions.
But it doesn't work the dark Doctor Strange
tricks and pulling him into a shadow and tries
to show him a vision of Christine to convince
them, which doesn't work either love the knockdown
drag out fight that they have to their freefall.
But in the end, he still winds up losing gets
absorbed by dark Doctor Strange within successfully
uses his magic to bring Christine back, but
in doing so destroys all of reality in the
reason why she starts turning instantly into
that same black magical do nothingness.
Like everyone else melting into nothingness.
Is because he did bring her back to life.
Yes, but the University brought her back to
was in the process of losing cohesion as reality
continues to crumble into nothingness.
He erects that barrier around them.
The watcher reiterates his message from before
not being able to intervene it would doom
the rest of the multiverse.
Like I said I think that's all set up for
future episodes that the deal with the guardians
of the multiverse.
The watcher is also correct he is not a God
he just from a race of beings that are superpowerful
and when Doctor Strange asked him to punish
me not the world.
I believe that's also meant to be set up for
the guardians of the multiverse.
Like his penance that he'll serve for what
he's done here destroying his reality will
be to become a guardian of the rest of the
multiverse is that this protective barrier
these erected around them just long enough
to say goodbye to her one more time before
she disappears and you notice as the episode
goes out fades to black the barrier is still
there around him.
So he has survived the destruction of his
reality like I said I do believe will be crossing
over with other characters in future episodes.
But even though it's meant to be a super downer
ending most if not all the marvel what if
comic stories had downer endings if he did
spot any big Easter eggs in the episode that
I didn't talk about during the video just
right them blown the comments.
It was a pretty solid episode I think is probably
my favorite one so far is only getting a crazier
from here my full marvel what if episode five
video will post next week and might wind up
being the Kilmonger iron man episode about
a couple more big bonus videos that I'll be
posting the next couple of days make sure
you have alerts enabled so you don't miss any of that
more Spider-Man videos everyone click
here for my full Spider-Man no way home trailer
breakdown and Easter eggs and click here to
learn what's going on with Doctor Strange 2
multiverse of madness and X-Men crossover.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see in the next video!